the independent energy expert Cornelia
mayor and Cornelia so this word
stagflation we overdue I think we are
overdoing it a little bit because yes we
had some inflationary pressures but the
inflationary pressures is not just oil
it is also that the pound tumbled
because of brexit in the wake of brexit
so we are we did the economy has done
has started exports have done quite well
because the pound went down so the big
worry is that if interest rates as it
looks go up by 25 basis points this
Thursday because the Bank of England
says so then we negate all the positive
of the we negate all the positive of the
Abdi of the increased exports although I
guess for Philip Hammond it's quite good
because he gets increased oil revenues
when he gets increased all the revenues
but the problem is due to the increased
oil revenues really sort of balance
balance the balance that what it will do
to the to the exports of normal you know
manufactured goods it's what's been
behind this rally over the last year or
so is it demand led or is it supply
driven it's both when you look at it the
demand side has come up and we did the
world economy is doing better than
expected as the IMF says and demand OPEC
says this year 1.5 million barrels a day
more next year 1.4 million barrels a day
more I a says something similar a is as
something similar so all the big
agencies say say it's going up that's
one and the other one is last year in
December you may remember that OPEC said
they would take 1.4 1.5 million barrels
run for 2 million barrels out of the out
of circulation and they had an agreement
with 10 other countries known OPEC
countries to take another 600 barrels
out of the 600,000 powers out of the
market so all in all we have taken out
of the market 1.8 million barrels with
pretty stunning and adherence that's
quite a
for numbers and in terms of overall
daily consumption that's that's what
roughly well that's roughly about two
percent or so but you know as the
markets were starting to rebalance this
is actually very good and what was
really interesting is that two weeks
back when President Trump said he would
not renew the Iran the Iran nuclear
agreement and be worried about sanctions
and when the current Iraqis went and
took over cook and we were worried about
the pipeline from Kurdistan into turkey
into Jhon suddenly for the first time in
about three four years that geopolitical
risk premium came up and oil showed up
what's all this gonna mean for the US
shale producers because they very much
supplanted the Saudis as being the sort
of swing producer globally hadn't yes
and and they are still doing well the
problem is how much can how much more
can the Permian give but there are new
things like who Utica which is more gas
well then there's you ties now the new
hot thing so New Mexico so there are
other there are other places what's
really interesting there is that some of
the that was was used to be in
intrapreneurial space with lots of small
entrepreneurial companies with risk
capital but Chevron and Exxon have moved
in there these days one out of five
barrels that excellent produces is
actually shale oil it's very interesting
in terms of we were talking just now
about the the geopolitical ramifications
of higher all I mean for oil importers
higher crude prices it's a tax on growth
but other other benefits for the world
in terms of things like Russia I mean
Russia's been in recession for the last
couple of years
Putin did some pretty wacky things to
take people's minds off it at home
didn't it is it a positive
it's a real positive it's a real
positive for Russia and you know they
only said they would take out of about a
million barrels a day 11 million barrels
a day they're taking out 300 thousand
powers a day so every incremental penny
really goes right back into their
pockets for the sound is it's important
because half this as they said last you
know last week they have this grand
vision on on re in vain
take the country and they need the money
from increased oil production and they
need it also for the Aramco
privatization
let's bring in Amrita Sen she's chief
oil analyst at energy aspects and rate
it good to see you there how high do you
think the crude price can go from here
look fundamentals look very very solid
right now I mean Brent's at about sixty
there's a little bit of an infantry
overhang to clear but there's no reason
why we shouldn't be getting into kind of
65 zone in the next couple of months it
won't be straight away but we have drawn
inventories at an unprecedented rate and
in terms of OPEC they're meeting next
month in Vienna do you think they and
the Russians are likely to extend their
production cuts further into next year I
think there's this is this poses an
interesting question because of course
if prices were lower I think it would
have been a more sanguine deal that yes
we would yes they would meet in November
and you could see them extending by you
know anywhere between six and nine
months and that is what the indications
were but with prices at $60 I think
there's a little bit of you know they're
getting a bit of cold feet that it
should prices continue to go to what 65
or higher but let me be specific over
here WTI prices and WT is trading
substantially lower than Brent right now
then they could see shale production
from the US rise again and that's their
worry having said that I will make this
very very clear that we don't think this
cooperation is necessarily going to end
I think this is very much a long-term
cooperation between OPEC and non-opec
countries however whether they decide to
extend the deal in November or not given
that prices have risen so much still
needs to be seen maybe they extend it in
March they have to meet again then all
right I'm Rita son-in in the office
there and Cooney lemare here good to see
you both thank you